hallo leute wie ihr wisst gibt es im
deutschen einige fremdwörter die aus
anderen sprachen ursprünglich kam und
dann eingedeutscht wurden vor kurzem
haben wir schon mal ein video darüber
gemacht mit französischen wörtern das
seht ihr hier und heute sind wir extra
nach münchen gefahren um dort zu treffen
denn wir wollen herausfinden welche
englischen wörter gibt es in der
deutschen sprache und wie sind die
eingedeutscht oder adoptiert worden
einige wörter die sind noch ganz die
werden aus gesprochen und geschrieben
wie im englischen original und einige
wörter sind stark in deutschland und wir
gucken jetzt mal wie die wörter
heutzutage aussehen
dann bist du reich ich bin bereit ich
habe noch nicht die liste gesehen ich
freue mich sehr so erdogan
das add-on die adapter der adapter also
die dab der kuh zu wissen ja weil im
englischen haben die wörter ja kein kein
sender alle einig lage ein geschlecht
und wir müssen natürlich uns dann 1
ausdenken was meistens klappt weil es da
so paar regeln für gibt aber manchmal
gibt es auch wörter die haben dann
einfach mehrere zum beispiel das und der
notebook und so was die das e mails
erkennt der account die checks wir sagen
auch auf deutsch checken aber ich habe
hier noch eine variante abchecken
manchmal gibt es tatsächlich wörter die
werden eingedeutscht und bekommen noch
ein deutsches triflex davor den nächsten
beiden sind sehr ähnlich und auf deutsch
kann man auch sagen ab danson und
ablösen und dann damit man zum beispiel
dass man ja tanzen ist normal da
benutzen das deutsche wort aber ab
danson ist wenn du völlig verrückt denn
genau das ist dana dance gerade total ab
das darf man nach deutsches habe ich das
ist wie ich tanze
[Gelächter]
oder wenn jemand ein spiel verloren hat
oder meine mannschaft richtig schlecht
gespielt hat kann sagen sie haben voll
abgelöst
computer auf deutsch kann sagen sich
auspowern
das heißt dass man mit etwas so viel
energie verbringt zb beim sport dass man
dann ist die energie weg haha ich bin
total ausgepowert heute das ist auch ein
interessanter aspekt dass man bei der
übernahme von wörtern aus anderen
sprachen neue wörter schaffen kann
erstmal the baby das baby der backpacker
der brunch das brand ich liebe wie das
klingt noch mal dass brand noch sagen
dass brand nun aber ja viele leute vor
allem ältere leute die nicht noch nicht
so viel englisch gelernt haben früher
gesenkt wir gehen branchen morgen was
schwierig für mich manchmal ist wenn
deutsche sorte wird solche worte
benutzen besteht das oft nicht weil ich
denke nicht plötzlich sagt man plant
also sage ich das was ist dass du dir
sorgen rück übersetzt jain wie würde das
auf amerikanischen ja genau der banker
der bunker der bestseller der currywurst
ist natürlich auch ich glaube nicht dass
das amerikanische ist aber curry
sprechen wir total deutsch aus das kommt
aber nicht aus dem deutschen es wird
auch nicht durch geschrieben und wir das
habe ich selber erst bei meiner
recherche herausgefunden dass das
eigentlich ein englisches wort ist was
wir die ganze zeit immer nur deutsch aus
fahren die currywurst heißt eigentlich
nicht currywurst
kerry ich kann das nicht mal richtig
aussprechen in englisch schien
entschieden
und das nächste des zds tatsächlich gibt
es ganz viele werben die wir übernommen
haben und die werden dann einfach mit
dem bn gebildet am ende entschieden
dessen und dann auch deutsch kollidierte
dutt ist ok in diesem fall bedeutet ihm
alles oder nur mit einem partner
wenn du eine rein spiel rennteams
fremdgehen das nur ein paar entschieden
dass man spiele meistens ja interesse
dafür dass es in deutschen kein wort ok
fremdgehen ist nur in einer beziehung
und schieden ist halt das was man in
einem spiel mehr ob der und manual das
drop-down-menü die e mail
ich habe auch bemerkt dass viele
deutsche sagen
bei e mail einfach mehr also ich habe
dir ein mail geschickt und dann is far
geldmittel post wirken
ich hatte auch keine wahl hatte eine
mail geschickt ja genau
puma gab der epic fail
ich glaube das ist erst vor kurzem also
das ist noch nicht richtig etabliert
aber es stand schon in der wikipedia
liste mit deutschen anglizismen
also man kann tatsächlich sagen was für
ein epic fail fitnessstudio das
fitnessstudio und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob es wirklich auf englisch
fitness studio heißt also vielleicht in
großbritannien ich weiß nicht aber in
den usa es ist ein job ja stimmt
der grill und auf deutsch aber ich auf
englisch es ist ein
die grillparty was ist ein hacker ohne
computer haben
ja da hacker der hamburger der hamburger
das hört sich wirklich an die jemand aus
hamburg ja ja das ist auch der hamburger
ist auch die person aus hamburg nicht
hamburger und das essen erst noch
hamburger der internet das internet
der insight information which insider
es gibt auch manche auf deutsch das
insiderwissen es gibt manche worte die
werden dann englisch deutsch vermischt
und bilden ein neues ein neues
kompositum mit bindestrich dazwischen
das insiderwissen die
insiderinformationen und dann wird es
schwierig weil da muss man manchmal das
erste wort englisch und das zweite wort
deutsch aussprechen interview
interviewen zusammen das macht ja nicht
nur mit seiner gitarre den nationalpark
nasa die nasa ja und ich würde nie sagen
die nato das ist interessant weil diese
all diese internationalen organisationen
sind ja alles englische akronyme von
englischen wörtern
aber wir sprechen die dann trotzdem
deutsch aus also nasa nato uno the
paddock das paddel wie beim tischtennis
nähe zum rudern die partie das prepaid
handy
handy ist so ein sch ein anglizismus von
dem wir denken das ist ein englisches
wort ist es immer ganz da pullover der
pullover aber ihr benutzt das nicht in
ein in den usa nicht aber ich frage mich
die kleidung um darin sitzen ja das ist
tatsächlich ziemlich ekelhaft aber so
das puzzle das ist so schön das ist ganz
lieben zu posten
der radar der rekord und das ist so für
musik nein das ist dann eine
schallplatte oder eine platte und der
rekord ist wenn man etwas besonders
gutes macht und so ok also auch nicht
ein unterländer unterlagen oder halo 1
das ist eine einnahme und das ist auch
interessant wenn ein wort ein englisches
volk nur für eine bedeutung
auf deutsch wird und nicht die andere
den vito italien und das gibt es ganz
oft weil die englischen wörter wenn ja
dann übernommen wenn es auf deutsch kein
präzises wort dafür gibt und das heißt
manchmal kann es sein dass ein wort
viele bedeutung hat unter den deutschen
dann aber nur genau eine war ja genau
dieses eine wort fehlt der rockmusik die
rockmusik zu scrollen zu stoppen und das
wird heute nicht einkaufen oder
strickkleider ja genau alles außer
lebensmittel
da sagen wir einkaufen das board der
sport nein wir sagen normalerweise der
sport ich mache jetzt nur ein witz wege
stephan weil der
was denkt das steak manche leute sagen
wir auch das steak das steak das spray
das spray tattoo tätowieren
das ist interessant hier wurde sogar die
schreibweise angepasst mit tätowieren
lässt der tour ist wenn der trend
wir sagen auch deutsch twittern oder
tweeten jürgen aha na ja ich bin ein
bisschen eingedeutscht
ich weiß nicht jetzt wie das tatsächlich
auf englisch ist also ich weiß es ist
nicht die usb stick ja aber ich weiß
nicht ich glaube vielleicht nur usb
flash für das saastal ja aber ich habe
tatsächlich irgendwie zwei jahre
gebraucht dass ich irgendwie das gezeigt
habe dass ich war immer irgendwie
irgendwelchen internationalen konferenz
oder so und habe immer gefragt so ja
durch und usb stick und alle so hey was
soll das also ja ich dachte ja klar
stick usb das ist doch ein englisches
wort ja ja es ist aber nicht okay also
ich glaube in den usa habe ich immer
dafür wifi gesagt ja frei und im
deutschen nutzen der wlan und wir denken
das ist auch ein englisches wort aber
wenn man dann in die usa fällt und sagt
hier
do you have also habe ich weiß die st
der zombie
zombie man sieht also es gibt
unterschiedliche aussprachen deutschen
und meine mein verständnis ist dass es
in unterschiedlichen jahrzehnten
verschiedene englische wörter gab die in
die deutsche sprache gekommen sind und
je nachdem wie gut die leute damals
englisch gesprochen haben sind die dann
eingedeutscht worden oder nicht und ich
glaube heutzutage benutzt man also die
meisten leute jungen leute die jetzt auf
wachsen die haben englisch gut in der
schule gelernt die übernehmen einfach
denn die englische schreibweise und
sprechweise aber die älteren worte die
irgendwie vor 100 oder 50 jahren
eingedeutscht wurden die wurden dann
tatsächlich auch deutsch ausgesprochen
sowie nationalpark oder tätowieren
so was mache ich hier ja und es gibt
auch noch so etwas wie shining zizmann
das ist noch ein interessantes wort und
darüber hast du auch schon mal
recherchiert oder ja genau das habe es
und das sogar ein kapitel in deinem buch
dazwischen ja genau
ja das finde ich das wirklich
interessant es gibt im deutschen einige
wörter die englisch klingeln und wir
denken die kommen aus dem englischen
die existieren aber gar nicht im
englischen und dann denken wir ja cooles
trendiges wort aus den usa kinder auch
als ich und du hast jetzt ein kleines
quiz für mich du hast nämlich ein ganzes
kapitel in dana hat in ihrem buch you go
mi an der koki ihr seht es geht also um
sprache deutsch englisch und da hast du
nämlich darüber geschrieben das buch ist
auf deutsch aber das handy und erkenne
ich das sind die klassischen deutschen
und showmaster gibt es nicht im
englischen nein wie nennt man denn die
menschen
niederhof sensi
das war unser video über anglizismen im
deutschen bevor ihr jetzt wieder
schreibt die sprache verändert sich zu
schnell und die deutschen sollen nur
deutsche wörter benutzen
es ist einfach so die sprache ist immer
im fluss und das ist das interessante
und wir können das nur beobachten und
daran teilhaben und ich finde es immer
ganz interessant diese diskussion dann
zu sehen
ich freue mich mal auf eure kommentare
was ihr dazu zu sagen habt
welche wörter gibt zum beispiel in euren
sprachen jede sprache bewegt sich und
ich glaube das ist wichtig das zu wissen
dass man eine sprache niemals freihalten
kann von äußeren einflüssen denn alle
sprachen sind irgendwann mal entstanden
und haben sich verändert
danke dass du dabei war sie den vielen
dank es hat so viel spaß gemacht wenn
ihr lust habt mehr über die deutsche
sprache zu erfahren dann checkt mal
checkt man das buch aus
dann könnt ihr dann ist abgrenzen mit
dem neu gesammelten wissen ja genau ich
freue mich dass du dabei warst oder dass
wir bei dir heute zu gast sein dürfen
dankeschön
danke fürs zuschauen und ihr könnt auch
ein mitglied von the german werden das
geht hier ihr könnt dann us kanal
abonnieren das geht auch hier und wir
sehen uns nächste woche wieder ciao